so Ken Starr was just on the show if
you're over nineteen kind of a big deal
a couple decades ago Ken Starr was at
the very center of the news cycle every
news cycle for years one of the most
polarizing and talked about people in
history at the time anyway and then he
would dark for about two decades and now
he's back to remind us of what the
Clintons were really like Mark Steyn was
there then he's here now and he never
forgets anything Mark Steyn what do you
make of that what do you make here Ken
Starr is back and we have another
special counsel in progress now 20 years
later did nobody learn the lesson no
that's that's true and Bob Bala
gets a much better press than Ken Starr
did as you know he's the most he's the
most genial fellow he's he's got this
boyish smile and he gets on with
everybody people poured a bucket of mud
over him day after day after day for
years and when you scraped it off he's
like he was just now beaming ken starr
same as always taking it I don't think
it was a good idea I don't think the
idea of an Independent Counsel is a good
idea but I think ken starr's ken starr's
point is actually more important that
the that the bargain the Democrats made
with Clinton corruption back in the 90s
was not actually in the interest of
American public service but actually not
in the interest of the Democrat Party
either you know it always worked out
well for the Clintons after impeachment
Hillary got a Senate seat in a in a
state she'd never lived in while poor
old Al Gore couldn't even get dragged
along the finish over the finish line in
the presidential election the Clintons
worked out for the Clintons and nobody
else but doesn't it I mean we only have
a minute left and this is a deep
question but it did work out they skated
on everything they beat a bunch of legal
charges and they got incredibly rich why
aren't they happy they're clearly so
unhappy why because I think it's never
enough the whole point of them
just to get rich and get richer and keep
winning Bob Smith who was my senator in
New Hampshire at the time he said I with
the engagement trial he said he's won
he's always wins let's move on and then
suddenly they didn't win and they can't
stand it and they want to keep coming
back whether it's Hillary or Chelsea or
whoever's next it's it's the winning
it's the money it's never enough no it
never is and you think maybe you get to
a certain age you get rich enough you'd
be happy but it's eluded them it's kind
of pointed mark great to see you as
always